foreign
what's up James
hey Dr John thanks for taking my call I
really appreciate it of course man
what's up
hey so first things first go Astros how
to get that in there yeah dude they are
not going very fast right now no but
there's a lot of games so we're good
smoking like a true Astro fan okay
there's a lot of games ahead so what's
up Hey so uh relationship question for
you
um I'll just get right to it and then
give you a few bullet points
so how do I set boundaries with my
brother-in-law who is getting a divorce
from my sister that'll keep me healthy
emotionally
did he leave is he leaving your sister
uh I mean that's kind of
getting I mean he's the one that filed
but I mean there's always more to it you
know so what's what tell me more to it
so
um
their relationship or what I'm calling
about yeah what you're calling about
okay so I'll give you a few bullet
points so
in uh January they filed for divorce and
so just kind of out of respect for them
I
didn't talk to him much
um I mean there's attorneys involved and
just to support my sister 100 and just
out of respect so
um like I said didn't talk with him much
until last week
um he sent me some texts kind of
emotionally charged saying I had
abandoned him and
he didn't know what I was getting at by
not talking to him and just sort of
guilt-tripping me a little bit so I
responded and
eventually I just said hey let's just
meet up for lunch and talk about it
Thank You For Being the adult in the
room
well I mean I kind of gave in for a few
texts but eventually I mean that's like
super Dawson's Creek Avril Lavigne like
you're not my friend anymore I'm sending
a mean text it's like bro you're adults
man just like let's read up but good for
you okay yeah yeah
it was good it was good
um it was productive I told him hey
nothing's out of spite I just I gotta
support my sis you know she's
um I mean her husband's leaving her
dad's not really in the picture I'm the
only brother so I just want to be there
for however I can we see mature adult
and and hear that out
yes yeah he actually did it's not what
he wanted to hear
um
but he said hey okay I mean that hurts
but I'm gonna follow your lead moving
forward
so I said hey I can't give you a time
frame and I know it's unfair but I'm
treading out familiar Waters here yeah
you know I I don't think there's
anything unfair about it to be honest
with you
um
I know that that marriages go two-way
well I know marriages go two ways
there's always two sides to a story and
sometimes the person who finally just
calls it
um is the bad guy right
um
and so he may not be the bad guy here it
may just be who knows what's going on
but at the end of the day you get to
decide who you're you are in
relationship with and similar if you had
called and said hey this is like one of
my closest friends in the world we we've
we're our our families play together we
we are go out all the time
and I'm not gonna lose my friendship
just because him and my sister didn't
work out and my sister's having a bad
attitude about it I would tell you she
didn't get a vote either
what you need to know is whatever you
decide is going to come with a cost and
just be okay with that
I say be okay with it it's not like it's
gonna be fun but at the end of the day
um be okay with it I know some folks who
have
um
filed for divorce and they imagine the
other side of divorce as though
everything on their life is the same
they just removed the one
um puzzle piece that was their husband
or wife and then just replaced it with
somebody who's more fun and cool and
prettier and younger or whatever
but they think that their friends are
going to stay the same they're they're
living arrangements are going to stay
the same into the I it's it never ceases
to amaze me how surprised people are
that when you file for divorce when you
marriage when your marriage breaks up
when you choose to call out on your
marriage it affects everything it blows
up your friendship circles it blows up
where you hang out it usually affects
your living Arrangement your income it
blows up everything and so
um he's going to want to try to hang on
to every bit of this is the way my life
used to be and not take full
accountability for it no dude everything
you know about your former life is over
now and you're going to figure out what
comes next see what I'm saying and
that's not your that's not your
responsibility to Carrie
the the other side of this is this as
your sister said I don't want you
talking to him I don't want you meeting
with him I don't want him in in your
life
no no she's she knows we're all gonna
have to figure out her relationship with
him moving forward so why'd you choose
this why do you why is your solution I
gotta cut him out
well I mean it's not cut out completely
I mean I
uh I just don't want to say something
that might be used for I don't know
maybe the attorneys or something like
that and and to be honest with you it
was kind of taxing emotionally
to see him you know break down while I
was talking to him and then
talk to my sister and see her breakdown
and I just feel like being in the middle
of it is it brings me though you know
yeah dude hold on hold on man you're in
relationship with these people is your
sister and your best friend
like this is what this is what we do
when we have family members and best
friends we get in the mud with them
like if you only want to be around have
friends and family members unless
they're not bumming me out bro dude that
makes you not a great friend and not a
great brother or sister
like it of course it's gonna bring you
down and that's why you're there like
that that's the role you play in the
season is sitting with people in their
grief the picture they had for their
life is is exploded it's gone and that's
what friends and Community does and so I
I guess I would challenge you man
um
to not see this like man it's just kind
of bumming me out bro like I I just I
don't know I don't know I don't identify
with that I attitude at all
I want to be there for my friends when
they're hurting bad
I got you and I get
um you not wanting to say something dumb
hopefully you're
you trust yourself enough to not do that
maybe you don't maybe you don't but what
do you think you're gonna say
um I don't know maybe something that my
sister has told me that he doesn't know
about or if
I don't know
like I said this is unfamiliar to me
um so one one important thing let me
tell you a couple of things that guide
my life okay maybe this helps number one
especially in this situation I don't
keep secrets I'm out
I don't keep secrets so if someone's
like hey I need to tell you this but you
can't nope I'm out I don't want to hear
that that's for you and your attorney
um I'm not I'm not the person When the
Smoke Clears and all this we can talk
but right now it's not smart the um the
second part is my buddies know my
closest friends in the world now
if they leave their wives I'll love them
I will I will love them to the end of
time but their wife is welcome at my
house then come stay with me now they
don't have to and if they don't want to
then my buddies can come stay too but
I'm not going to just go to war against
their spouse because they they chose to
make decisions
because their spouse is one of my close
friends too and I'm talking about my
core my core group of people
um and so
I think you can do both
but also I'm not worried about
accidentally saying something that I
shouldn't be saying or I I I'm I'm a
pretty good Vault of a friend and so I'm
not worried about saying this or saying
that like ads it sounds like at the end
of the day brother there's you need to
be confident in your emotional maturity
and maybe this is the first big heavy
thing that you've experienced with your
friends and your family but
unfortunately dude this is the rest of
your life marriages are gonna blow up
your friends are gonna do stupid stuff
your friend's gonna go to jail you're
gonna get fired from your job someone's
gonna pass away this is the future and
so being able to handle that in a
dignified way that honors people's
confidentiality that doesn't just write
people and cut people out
um that doesn't just like you hide
because man you're making me feel bad
because you're sad of course that's
that's when friends go in that's when
friends go in when the building's on
fire
um
that was tough man but I want you to
reconsider your role in their lives
maybe lean on you you all been together
for Seasons just like this
Seasons just like this
if you can't do it at least yeah good
for you you know enough about yourself
to know I can't do that but my hope is
you can head into the storm instead of
running away from it